[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED FINKLER: My
name is Ed Finkler.
Like I said, thanks Josh
for that great introduction
and for getting me up here.
We go back a little
ways, so it was nice.
And I'll try not to tell any
terrible stories about him
in his young age and the
music we used to write.
So anyway, yeah, my
name is Ed Finkler
and this is a talk, stronger
than fear, mental health
in the developer community.
So who am I?
Well, you heard a
little bit about that.
But at a basic level I'm a dad.
I'm a husband.
I'm a developer type.
I've been a developer for a long
time, an occasional musician,
kind of a big ultra
nerd, like nerdy stuff.
I have a very large
collection of vintage video
games in my basement, to
the chagrin of my family.
But I also have
a mental illness.
Or actually I have a couple.
I have two I've
been diagnosed with.
They called that
co-morbidity, which
sounds like you're going
to be murdered twice.
But it just means that
you have two things.
And I'm just a lay person here.
I'm not a doctor
or a psychologist
or mental health
professional of any kind.
I'm certified in something
called mental health first aid.
And I'll talk about
that a little bit.
But I'm here to
talk about what it's
like to have a mental
illness from my perspective,
my perspective as a kind
of a regular person,
as a developer,
as somebody who's
worked as a tech professional
for the last 20 years,
and also talk about how
mental health effects
our community and our industry,
people who work in this
and the community of
people who work in tech
and bring things together.
So like he said, I work at a
company called Graph Story.
I'm a CTO there.
This is weird because for 20
years I have been a developer.
And now suddenly I've been
thrust into the executive team.
Which it's a small startup,
which pretty much means
I do the same stuff, but if
I make the wrong decision,
we'll just crash and burn and
everyone will lose their job.
So that's cool.
Anyway, but that's
not what I'm here
to talk to you about today.
I have an informal
survey though for you.
And this is going to
be one of the things
where you've got to get
your wings shaken up here
and you're going to want to
raise your hands because--
also, you have to raise them
up because I can't see so well.
There's so many cool lights
here that light me up
beautifully that I can't see
you as well as I'd like to.
But I want to have
a question for you.
How many of you need contacts
or glasses to see effectively?
I would like you to raise
your hand if you do.
There are a couple
of you who do not.
I'm very impressed with you.
Your genetics are very good.
Thank you.
How many of you are free
to tell people that you
wear glasses or contacts?
Are any of you
afraid to tell people
that, that you have
this ocular device
that you need to use
to cope in society?
That's ultimately why
we have those things.
So nobody's answered yes.
OK, gotcha.
That's kind of expected.
Have you ever had somebody
tell you, could you try harder,
try seeing harder?
Has anyone ever
said that to you?
Has anyone ever suggested
that you squint instead of--
I think somebody's
shaking their head.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for that.
We all should
apologize for that,
because that's a terrible
thing to have to tell anybody.
So in general, we're
pretty comfortable the idea
that most of us need some
kind of support or help thing
or some sort of medical
device that allows us
to cope in society as normal.
Because as humans age, their
eyes tend to get crappy.
Now OK, that's fine and dandy.
So another issue, another
condition, diabetes--
my brother and my dad both
developed type two diabetes.
So I'm probably not in
great shape in that regard.
But I'm curious about this.
How many of you would feel
comfortable in the workplace,
maybe not excited about
it, but OK in the workplace
if diabetes came up
and you discussed that?
I would like you to raise
your hand if you would be
comfortable with discussing it.
OK, so most people would
be comfortable about it.
Yeah, maybe not the
most exciting thing.
Maybe you wouldn't
be like, hey, I
had a great weekend, diabetes.
You wouldn't do
that necessarily.
But you'd be
comfortable with it.
And it's a serious condition.
It's a serious condition.
Lots of people deal with it.
If untreated, it can be fatal.
It can be bad stuff.
Now another condition that
has touched a lot of our lives
is cancer.
I lost my brother two years ago
to cancer, one of my brothers.
And that is a difficult
thing for a lot of us.
I think most of us,
It's touched our lives
in one way or another.
We know somebody or we've
dealt with it ourselves.
Now I want to ask that
same question about cancer.
How many of you would feel OK--
again, not excited,
but feel OK discussing,
if cancer came up
in the workplace,
having that discussion?
Somebody mentioned and said, oh
you know, my brother, turns out
he has cancer.
Raise your hand if
you would feel OK
with that, if that
discussion would be like,
I'm OK with that?
Not everybody-- not
everybody necessarily.
It can be tough.
And it can be tough
because of the emotions
that are attached with that.
A lot of us have lost
people because of that.
How many of you would
feel comfortable
talking to your boss about
a mental health issue?
Raise your hand.
Interesting.
How many of you would be
OK talking with a colleague
about a mental health issue?
So 1 and 1/2 maybe.
I got zero on boss.
Those are the lowest
numbers I've ever seen.
I've given this talk 50 times.
How about a friend or
family member, somebody
you're close with?
Most people, our hands don't
exactly shoot up quickly
when we talk about this stuff.
That's interesting.
Think about that.
Think about, while we're
talking about this stuff,
compare that with
cancer and how much
we talk about that in
our popular culture
and how much we talk
about mental health.
And I want you to think
about that while we're
discussing this stuff.
Now I'll talk a little
bit about myself.
That's one of my
favorite subjects
is the diagnoses that I have.
I have two things that
I've been diagnosed with.
One is generalized
anxiety disorder.
And the ones that I tend to tell
people my experience with it
is that I have fight or
flight reactions when
it's not appropriate.
It is appropriate to have a
fight or flight reaction when
my life is in danger.
If there is a lion
that's going to attack me
and I need to either run away
or roundhouse kick this lion,
that is an appropriate time
to have a fight or flight
reaction.
My brain says, you
need to be in this mode
because you might need
to beat up something
or you might need to run
as fast as hell to get away
from this thing to survive.
That is an appropriate time
your brain tells your whole body
to kick in.
Your physiology changes.
Hormones and chemicals start
pumping through your system.
Lots of stuff happens.
Physiology dramatically
shift from a normal state
to a high stress state.
And it changes because it
is a survival mechanism.
It is not appropriate to have
a fight or flight reaction when
you're going to meet friends at
a bar that you've never been to
and you're standing
outside, and you're
so uncomfortable with the
idea of going into this place
and you're not sure exactly
where they're sitting
and you don't really know
what it's like in there
and what's the layout like
and you just get freaked out,
and you decide that maybe I
should just go back to my car
and sit in my car
for a few minutes
and then just
drive home instead.
That has happened
to me many times.
That's happened
It's not appropriate
to have it where you're
afraid to take the bus or other
kinds of public transportation
because you don't understand
the payment system
and you're so afraid of being
embarrassed, of standing up
and people being mad at you
because you're slowing things
down and stuff like that.
I just don't ever take those.
I don't take the bus.
I don't take trains.
It helps.
I don't live in Chicago
so there's less of that,
but there are at least
buses where I live.
And that is not an
appropriate time
to have those kind of reactions.
But I do.
I do have those
kinds of reactions
in those situations,
particularly situations
where I feel like I don't
understand the rules
or like I'm not competent
enough to handle this.
I get very, very
deeply uncomfortable.
My brain says something's
wrong, and you
have to protect yourself.
It tells me that very loudly.
I also have ADHD, attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder.
And that's something that
gets thrown around a lot.
A lot of people kind of
talk about that stuff.
And there's some things that
are kind of typical that you're
used to that go along with ADHD.
And my experiences
with it, a lot of them
are similar, that as an
adult, I have trouble
focusing on single tasks.
So I often jump from one
thing to another a lot.
I also tend to avoid.
Avoidance is a whole
big thing, a big part
of my life that
I've struggled with,
avoidance of unappealing tasks.
And it's not stuff like,
well, you know, I don't really
feel like doing this right
now, but I'll get around to it.
It's been more like, yeah,
I will just never do that
and my water will get
shut off because I just
didn't get around
to paying the bills
because I kept forgetting.
And when I did do it, I was
like, I really don't want to.
I feel strangely like almost
almost anxious about it
and uncomfortable.
It's like I don't want to
deal with that right now.
I've had that happen.
I have the money.
I just didn't pay the bill.
But there's a couple
of other things
that often go hand-in-hand with
ADHD and the kind of stuff I
deal with.
And one of those
things is oftentimes,
I have these two
different things,
but they sort of go together.
I have what I usually say is
a low frustration threshold.
And this is fairly common
with people with ADHD,
that they often get
frustrated quickly,
especially if the way they
expect things to go changes
rather suddenly.
Most people aren't super
comfortable with that,
but they can adapt OK.
I have a very strong
emotional reaction to that,
oftentimes very--
and I think it ties in with an
idea that I feel uncomfortable
and I tend to get angry
in those situations.
I get frustrated.
Or I get very frustrated when
it feels like I'm just not
capable of doing something
and I get frustrated much more
quickly than seems normal
to the people around me,
than what seems like the norm.
The intensity of my emotions
is often much stronger
than it seems like it
is for other people.
Sometimes it feels like my
emotions are out of control
despite the fact that
I know logically I
am having a reaction
that is not in line
with the severity
of the situation.
I know that.
And yet I don't know how to turn
off that fire hose of emotion
that sometimes comes over me.
And sometimes I just have to
sequester myself off and wait
until it calms down because
otherwise I will say and do
things that are destructive.
I'll hurt people
around me that I love.
Emotionally I will act out
in different kinds of ways.
I'm also particularly good
at constructing bad outcomes
and hyperfocusing on them.
So an example would be--
this happened to
me more than once.
I've got an email
from the person
who is my manager,
my boss, and said--
hey, could you-- it's like
a Friday, late on Friday.
Hey, on Monday could you
come in and we could talk?
OK, all right, well
what's going to happen?
Oh, this is alarming.
I don't know what's going on.
Maybe he knew about
that thing that I did.
Was that thing--
oh my gosh, oh no.
And I would construct a scenario
where I'm losing my job.
We won't have any income.
I will be so shamed that
my family will abandon me.
We will lose our house.
I will be homeless.
My career is shot.
I will have nothing to live for.
And I will live the
next couple of days
unable to put that aside, unable
to take that out of my brain
and say, you know what,
that's ridiculous.
It's probably not
something like that.
Everything's going to be OK.
I want to tell myself that,
but it doesn't work that way.
Those emotions are
so strong and I'm
so good at constructing
those outcomes
and I have very
detailed lists of that.
And I live as if that is then
the predetermined outcome.
And I get in on Monday and
my boss says, "So how's
that project going?"
I'm like, "Oh, it's good.
Actually we finished that up.
Yeah, that was really good."
And meanwhile there's
sweat pouring off.
And I'm like, [BREATHS HEAVILY]
[EXHALES]
And it's like an
elephant has been sitting
on my chest for the
past three days,
and suddenly it just got off.
And there really wasn't
anything to worry about.
But I'm really, really good
at constructing those things,
really, really good at that.
So how do I deal with it?
I take medication is
one thing that I do.
I take about five
different things every day.
And that's something that helps.
And I've been dealing
with this 30 years.
And right now that's
the kind of cocktail
that works for me that helps
kind of keep myself in check.
It's not perfect.
It doesn't mean that
I never have symptoms,
but they're a lot less severe.
And I also see a
therapist every two weeks.
And I talk about what's
happened with me, why
I do the things that I do, try
to break down those scenarios,
try to break down sort of
the process of that behavior.
We go through thing a called
cognitive behavioral therapy,
which is a common thing that's
used with a lot of people
with anxiety disorders
that's pretty effective,
and talk about how and
why I do the things I do
and come up with
strategies to address that.
Basically like kind of having
a coach for your brain instead
of somebody who's telling
you to do sit-ups.
That's how it is
with my therapist.
Your therapist
could be different.
But that's how it
kind of works with me.
And those things help.
And I've gotten
better at things.
Stuff used to be a lot worse.
It's gotten better.
It impacts my work every day.
Every single day I am
living with my brain.
And the work that I do involves
thinking and solving problems
and figuring stuff out.
And things that affect the
way that my brain processes
work are pretty serious,
that affects my thinking
are particularly problematic,
potentially at least.
Now sometimes it
gives me superpowers,
absolutely gives
me super powers.
I'm really good at
certain aspects of my job
because of the way
my brain works.
I'm really good at constructing
negative outcomes, really good
at that.
I'm actually really good at
constructing outcomes period
and figuring out,
well, if we do this,
how is that going to impact
our system over here?
If we do this thing
in the back end,
how's that going to impact
how a user has to interact
with our system over here?
I tend to be kind of good
at anticipating security
issues for that reason.
How could somebody
attack our system
in such a way that [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not an expert.
I'm not some super infosec dude.
But I tend to be better
at that than some people.
I also, probably because
of some of the stuff
that I've dealt with in my life,
and I think a lot about how
things affect people, I
tend to empathize strongly
with the users.
And I think a lot about,
if we store data like this,
how does that impact the
way that the user is--
what they're able to do?
And ultimately as a developer,
that's sort of my job
is to make tools--
not sort of, it is my job is
to make tools that people use.
So it's rather helpful to be
able to empathize strongly
with users or people.
And it's often tough
because the people
who are building
this stuff often
have a lot of
difficulty understanding
what it's like to be a user
of the thing they make.
I'm a little bit better
at it than some people.
Not perfect, but I'm
a little bit better
than your average developer.
Sometimes it absolutely
gives me superpowers.
And sometimes it
absolutely ruins me.
Sometimes when
something happens,
when those emotions kick in
and I can't control them,
it craters my day completely.
It renders me unproductive.
I can not do my
work effectively.
I may not be able to
do my work period.
I just can't.
I cannot because I cannot focus.
I cannot concentrate.
I cannot do it.
The toughest thing with all
of this in my life and dealing
with this stuff where--
you know, I've been dealing
with stuff, particularly ADHD.
I've had that since
I was in school.
I know the whole thing.
I can think of things that I
did in second or third grade.
I was like, oh, that
was what was going on.
I wasn't diagnosed
until I was 27.
But been dealing with
that the whole time.
Anxiety and depression
started becoming much worse
when I was 12 or 13.
But in dealing with all
this, the toughest part of it
for me was that feeling
alone, feeling like you
were not like anyone
else around you,
feeling as if
everybody else seems
to be capable of
getting through life
and seems to be OK with this
stuff and they seem to get--
like in high school, they seem
to get their homework done.
They can read 100 pages of
Dostoevsky in a night and be
able to write something
about it, and I can't.
What's the problem?
Why can't I do this?
And you feel, and I
felt for a long time
that I was incapable
of living this life.
I always screw up
and I always fail.
And people that I love will
always grow tired of me
and leave.
And I will always do
that because I'm not
capable of sustaining--
doing things the right way.
I always blow up and
something goes wrong.
And that is how I felt for
a very, very long time.
But there's a lot of
people who feel like that.
A lot of people feel like that.
And that is what I'm
here to talk about.
And that is what we
formed OSMI to fight.
To talk a little bit about
how this affects us--
if we just look at the general
population, one in five adults
have a mental disorder in
any one year in the US.
That is 20% of the population.
That is looking at the
general population.
We'll get to the other
stuff in a minute.
But at the very basic, if
we look general population,
is it particularly abnormal
to have a mental disorder?
No, it's actually not.
In fact it's extremely common.
Anxiety disorders
are the most common.
They affect about 18%
of the population.
The numbers add up to more than
20% because you typically have,
again, co-morbidity.
You have issues
where people will
be diagnosed with multiple
things at the same time.
There is a World
Health Organization
study that was done in 2004 and
was released, I think, in 2008.
And it's the most recent
study of what they call
the global burden of disease.
This idea of disease
burden is a metric
they came up with which
combines premature death
and years lived with disability.
The idea is that they're
trying to measure
the impact that a disease
has on a population.
And in this study, they
found that the burden
of mental disorders was
the largest of all disorder
categories in North
America, larger
than cardiovascular disease
and larger than cancer.
And this is a quote
from this study.
"In all regions,
neuropsychiatric conditions
are the most important
causes of disability,
accounting for
around 1/3 of years
lost to disability among
adults aged 15 years over."
The most important cause
of disability World Health
Organization said.
That is across the globe.
Look at economic cost.
And these things are always
kind of a little fuzzy,
but it gives you some ideas.
Mental health conditions
are the second leading cause
of workplace absenteeism.
I don't know what the first
is, but second, mental health
conditions.
If we're just looking
at depression,
workers with depression
lose about 5.6 hours a week.
Workers without lose about 1.5.
That's a significant difference
in terms of hours lost.
And if we look at
sort of these numbers,
you try to attach
dollar figures to this.
Again, it's always
a little bit fuzzy.
But again, just
looking at depression,
just one major category
of mental health disorder,
$43.7 billion in absenteeism
from work, 200 million days
lost.
[INAUDIBLE] productivity,
direct treatment-- that
is enormous impact, and
I think particularly
if you think about people either
not working effectively or not
being able to be in
the office at all.
Because at the end of the
day, sick workers don't work.
It doesn't matter what
they're sick with.
People who are not healthy
are not as productive.
Doesn't matter if
they have a cold.
Doesn't matter if they got joint
pain and they can't get up,
they've got a back problem.
Doesn't matter if
they've got depression
or they've got anxiety.
It keeps them from
being as productive.
Now we have, for
a couple of years,
done what we call the mental
health in tech survey.
And this is an opt-in
survey, so self-selective.
So keep that in mind
if we go up and look
at some of the deeper results.
But these are results
from our 2016 initiative,
which has so far--
it's still open.
If you want to take it,
that would be great.
But this is data that
we had from 2016.
As of November 16, this
is what it collected.
And this just includes
people in the US,
and it just includes
non self-employed folks.
The reason I did that
was because there
are some differences
about the US compared
with other countries.
Typically in the
US, your workplace
is your primary conduit
for health care.
And people who are self-employed
have a different situation.
They are their own boss.
They can say, I'm going
to take a day off.
I'm going to go get
treatment for this.
They have different
opportunities.
People who are employed
by an organization
have to work with
that organization
and what they offer.
So the four questions that
I want to show you-- there
is tons of data in here from
all people all over the world.
And we have about
1,500 responses.
This is just the
folks in the US.
First question, do you think
that discussing a health
issue with your employer would
have negative consequences?
We asked about physical health.
72% of people said
no, about 3/4.
Maybe said 25%.
Yes said 4%.
4% said yes, excuse me.
Most people feel that if they
discuss a physical health
issue, probably would not
be negative consequences
in the tech workplace.
For mental health, only
about a third said no.
About 2/3 said yes or maybe.
That's a very
significant difference,
and I think underlines
the attitudes
and perception of mental
health and the consequences
for speaking about it
openly in the workplace.
Would you bring
up a health issue
with a potential
employer in an interview?
And again, we split this
between physical and mental.
With physical, no
and maybe, 76%.
It's not surprising.
Most people don't
want to give people
a reason not to hire them.
There are a number of issues
that could go into that.
Some would be like,
well, what does
it matter if my knee acts
up every once in a while?
Some people will tell you
there is no way in heck
you should ever tell
somebody that you're
planning on getting pregnant
because you will not
get the job.
That is a physical health issue.
So again, there's
lots of reasons.
But yes, 24%, not that high.
Let's compare that
with mental health.
Only 7% of people said yes.
Twice as many said no.
Maybe was a little bit
lower, probably being
eaten up by that no.
This in fact is higher than
the numbers-- or excuse
me, this is in fact a little
bit better than the numbers
we had in 2014 when we
last did this survey.
But it is still the case that
far fewer people would bring up
a mental health issue
versus a physical health
issue in an interview
because they believe--
I believe what you
can get from that
is they believe it is more
likely that a mental health
issue will be something that
eliminates them from contention
for that job.
Now this is despite the
fact that the Americans
With Disability Act says it
is illegal to do so if you
have more than 15 employees.
But it's also almost
impossible to prove it.
Does your employer
provide resources
to learn more about
mental health issues
and how to seek help?
Again, the workplace being
the primary conduit for health
care, how does the
workplace educate?
How does the workplace
point out these resources
and their availability
and things like that?
Only 30% said yes.
So 70% say no, employer
does not provide resources.
And another third
says, I don't know,
which I think is
just as bad as no.
2/3 of folks who are working
as tech professionals,
their employer
isn't providing them
with resources
about mental health.
Keep in mind what the
World Health Organization
said about the importance
of this and the burden
that it has on our society.
And the fourth and last question
that I'll show you here,
do you feel that
being identified
as a person with a mental health
issue would hurt your career?
And those numbers, only 12%
said no, I don't think it would,
or no it has not.
Everyone else says maybe or yes
I think it would or yes it has.
The perception is such
that people believe,
87% of folks who
answer these questions,
believe that being identified
as somebody with a mental health
issue is going to
hurt their career.
Why would they be
willing to discuss it?
willing to seek help?
Why would they be
willing to get better,
as that workplace is a
conduit for health care,
if they think there's going
to be negative consequences
for being known as that/ I
think that's a great question.
I think a lot of people are
very afraid to discuss it.
And it's tough because
change is really hard,
because we are scared.
Because frequently the
things I've encountered
is that people just
don't know what to do.
Employers are people
working in the workplace who
have some responsibility
for this stuff.
They're often afraid of
endangering their workplace,
saying the wrong thing,
giving the wrong advice,
and endangering their
workplace as a result--
endangering the health of the
organization, the existence
of the organization.
And people who are
employed are also
afraid of losing their
jobs, as is demonstrated
in the information we have.
People are afraid
to lose their jobs
because they're afraid that
they'll be identified as that.
Now at OSMI, there are
things we can do to help.
There's a lot of things
we can do to help.
But there's five things that
I think you can think about
right now that I think
will be effective
and I think will help.
The first thing is-- and
this is kind of a meta thing
and it's kind of hard, you
know, what does this mean?
Make a commitment to change.
But I think
fundamentally you have
to make a decision that you're
going to think and speak
about mental health differently
than you do right now.
And that's a matter
of changing yourself.
And it doesn't mean that you
have to go around and say, hey,
I've got this thing.
You know what, my brother,
he did this, my sister.
You do not have to be like me.
My therapist says I have a
confessional personality,
and that is very accurate.
I am a bit of an
oversharer, let's say.
And that works out
for stuff like this.
I'm good at this
because I can do that.
It doesn't mean you
have to be like this.
But being able to speak openly
about mental health issues
and speak to it without shame
and emphasize that there's
no shame in it, that
can change that world
around you, the social group
that interacts with you.
The social group you
interact with the most
is probably your workplace,
for better or for worse.
Those are probably people
you spend the most time with.
And you can have a significant
impact on those people
if you indicate to
them that they can
be less afraid of this stuff.
It is almost certain
based on the numbers
that there are people
in your social group
who are dealing with
mental health issues
and are afraid to
talk about, right now,
and you don't know who they are.
If you're able to speak
more openly about it,
you will help those people
feel safer, feel less stressed,
be mentally healthier, and be
more likely to seek treatment.
The second thing you can do
is we've created handbooks
specifically to help people
with these kinds of issues.
We have three.
They are available
for free as e-books.
There are handbooks for
employers and employees
on how to navigate ADA law
specifically dedicated to tech
workplaces and mental health.
So there's one for employers.
There's one for employees
dealing with ADA law.
The third one is how to create
supportive workplaces that
promote mental wellness
within the workplace.
All three of these
were developed
by Jennifer Akullian--
who has a PhD in psychology.
She works at Keen IO--
with a little bit
of help from me
and some help from
Johanne Wu, who
is a PhD in
organizational psychology.
These handbooks are
available for free.
They're Creative
Commons licensed.
And you can get them
right now at our website.
The third thing you
can do is take a course
called mental health first aid.
It's an eight hour course.
You can find lots
and lots of people
who will teach it in
this area, or in almost
any other part of the country.
It is available in 22
different countries.
In the US, I paid $50 to take
it and I got lunch with it.
It was a nice
little boxed lunch.
It was really pleasant.
And that was really cool.
And I learned a ton
about how to identify
if someone is in a
mental health crisis,
and then how to interact
with them most effectively
so that they are more
likely to seek help.
The key here is--
you might notice
I did not say how to fix
their problem for them.
That is not your job.
You are not trained for that.
I'm not trained for that.
Do not try to fix their problem.
People in tech,
particularly developers,
want to solve
problems for people.
Do not do this.
This is not your job.
You don't have to
fix everything.
You listen empathetically
and talk to them
in a way that's going to
encourage them to seek help.
I think it's a very
important course to take.
I particularly think
if you have anything
to do with managing people, this
is an essential course to take,
because you will
learn a lot about how
to interact with people in a
rewarding and positive way that
helps them succeed.
Tell people about the
work that you're doing,
the efforts that you're doing.
You take this class.
You read these handbooks.
Talk about it openly.
Share it on Twitter.
Share it on Facebook.
Share it on Google+.
Take a selfie when you're on
a break at the training course
and say hey, I'm
doing this thing.
It's really super cool.
Talk about it.
The more you talk about
it, the people around you
will be less afraid.
I guarantee it.
And the fifth thing, and I
think the most important thing,
this is about peer support.
And there's certain
organizations
like "Nami," NAMI--
can't write exactly
what it stands for,
National Association
of the Mentally Ill.
I probably got wrong.
Really focus on peer support.
Tell people that they
matter in your life,
how they impact
your life positively
and how strong and
great they are.
Everybody needs to hear this.
There are few of us who would
not benefit from hearing this
from the external sources.
There are few of us
who have a voice so
strong within
themselves that they
don't need it from anyone else.
Everybody needs to hear
this, particularly people
whose brains lie to them.
And my brain has been lying
to me for most of my life,
telling me that I didn't
matter, that all I
did was screw things up and
I was a burden to people.
So what's the upside for this?
And I don't talk about
just the upside for--
people, you feel better.
You feel that you've
done some moral good.
Why try to change the workplace?
What's the upside
for the workplace?
And why?
Because it benefits the
organization and everyone
in it.
Because mental wellness means
better employees, period.
Employees feel valued and secure
and work more effectively when
employers demonstrate
commitment to their well-being.
And people are going to
want to work for you.
People want to work someplace
that respects them fully
and that doesn't ignore
their well-being.
If I go back and I
think about the jobs
that I liked in my
career and the jobs
that I haven't liked,
the ones that are liked,
it did not have a lot to do
with the work I was doing.
It had to do with the people.
Did I have good relationships
with those people,
respectful relationships?
Did we have a mutual respect
and concern for each other?
The people that I
always work hardest for
were people that I felt like had
concern about me as a person.
They were concerned
about my well-being.
They wanted me to be
happy and healthy.
That's what makes for a good
workplace, not ping pong tables
and not free lunches.
That's what makes
for a good workplace.
In 2016, Open Sourcing Mental
Illness was not a nonprofit.
It was just a dude,
me, who had some ideas.
That's all it was.
I started to make
some changes though
to do some stuff that was
maybe a little more ambitious.
I had been speaking about mental
health for about three years
at different tech conferences.
It was mostly just me.
It's mostly just me.
We had started a little bit
of work on those handbooks
I talked about.
That was about it.
But in 2016 we had
some goals, and we
tried to get some
money for those goals.
Those goals primarily were
to become a legal nonprofit,
501(c)(3) to create e-books
and printed handbooks--
the handbooks we put together
were not e-books at the time.
You couldn't put
them on your Kindle
and fly around with
them, stuff like that--
to release an API and release
our survey data from 2016--
to do another survey too--
to do a video presentation
series, to do a video workshop,
and to get more people talking
and speaking about this.
So I wanted to raise some money.
I did this on Indiegogo.
Again, this was really people
were just giving me money.
There was no
organization behind it.
It was not tax deductible.
And so I'd done a couple
other ones before,
and they'd been
fairly successful.
And the goal--
2015 had been $5,000.
This year we said, oh,
hey, let's do $10,000.
This is going to be a
huge amount of money.
I'm kind of freaked
out about it.
But I'm going to ask
for it because I want
to do some ambitious stuff.
And I'm not going to sit
and be afraid of doing
ambitious things.
I'm really going to try to do.
So we did this on Indiegogo.
You get a reward.
You give us a
bunch of money, you
get a T-shirt and
stuff like that.
And our time to
goal was 72 hours.
So we raised that
$10,000 in 72 hours.
And the total that we raised
in 30 days was $22,481.
That was really,
really, really awesome,
amazing, humbling, and I think
speaks to how many people think
that this is really
important, that we're not
doing a good enough job,
that we can do a lot better.
And I think we can.
This is a list.
There's probably a couple
people missing from here,
but this is from 2015 and
2016, probably, again, about as
of November.
This is 275 bad asses
who all gave money.
They gave $10 or
they gave $1,000.
It varies, whatever.
But those are all really
amazing people who stepped up.
And it is incredibly humbling
to put something out there
and to realize that people
are willing to just give you
their money to do that.
That is crazy.
I didn't come out
here with, like, I
didn't write some paper.
I'm not a PhD in this.
I just think it's important.
And I tried to say
something about it because I
felt like I needed to.
And it's very humbling to
get that kind of support
from this community.
And as of recently,
we now have--
well actually there's a
couple of people missing here.
So we've got about 15 people
now are involved in this.
Used to just be me.
Now we've got about 15 people.
I was afraid to try
ambitious things.
All these people stepped
up and they said,
you know what you're
doing, it's really awesome.
I want to help too.
And they're doing amazing stuff.
People who are much smarter
and more capable than I am
are just doing amazing things.
And you can see up there
it says board members.
That's because we became
a nonprofit 501(c)(3)
organization as of
September of this year.
And that's a huge thing.
That's a huge thing.
It turned from just somebody
doing some stuff, which was me.
Now it is a real legal entity
and we're doing this work.
And all these donations are tax
deductible and stuff like that.
It's really cool.
We also have, this is
an in progress thing,
but this is our mental
health in tech 2016, a survey
graph and API.
This is an open project
you can help with.
You can also examine the data,
something like Kaggle.com.
We have some stuff there.
But you can do data
analysis with it.
It is all stored in a graph
database, a Neo4j graph
database.
And you can check
that stuff out.
And we're working on a
hypermedia API for it.
These are things
that you contribute
to if you're interested in.
If you're a data wonk,
check this stuff out.
You can check it out on Kaggle
or you can pull the stuff
directly out Neo4j.
If you want to help
with writing code
for this API, all cool stuff,
and also need help for like,
how do we visualize this data?
There's also something we did
call the OSMI forums, which
are formerly by a guy named Greg
Bauges who was here in Chicago.
He moved to New York last year.
And he works still at Twilio.
And he spoke a lot
about this kind of stuff
in the Ruby community.
And he had a site
called Devpressed.com.
And it was down for
a couple of months
because, like a lot
of things, he was busy
and something broke and
didn't have time to fix it.
We took that over.
We talked to him,
made this exchange,
and now it's the OSMI forum.
So otherwise it's the same.
It is a place for
people who work
in tech who are tech
professionals to talk
about their problems openly.
They can post-- they
make up an account name.
It doesn't matter.
We don't check and
validate that stuff.
They can post anonymously
about their problems
and talk with other
people in tech
about what's going on with
them, their specific issues.
And that's a forum we
took over this year.
And I should say I don't
even have a slide for it.
We are working on
this video workshop.
And we're going to
get a rough edit soon.
And that's aimed at HR
folks and executive teams.
That features Dr.
Akullian and Dr. Wu
and then me for
like five seconds
talking about why
this stuff matters
and why it needs to
matter in your workplace.
So we accomplished
most of our goals
or at least getting
partway there.
It's almost taken a little
while longer than it has been,
but we're doing OK.
Now one question sometimes I
get asked is, well why do you
call it Open Sourcing
Mental Illness?
And they make some kind of
joke about where's the code.
And you know, and
it's makes me pissed.
I don't know.
Hot button thing--
hot button thing.
In all my career, last
20 years of my career,
it's all been based
on open source stuff.
Not all the things that I've
created have been open source,
but everything that
I have done has
been based on open source
technology, every bit of it.
But I'm going to
assert that open source
culture and open source
community is not about code.
That is a mcguffin.
It's not about the code.
It's about learning
and sharing together.
And it's about growing together.
And it's about
open arms and it's
about open minds
and an open hand
to pull the next person up
and help them help themselves.
It's about a peer group that's
supportive and welcoming
and embraces each other
to help each other.
I started this in--
first time I talked about this
was at an unconference session
at php tek, which was out
in Roseland in May 16, 2013.
And I've done about 50
conferences since then.
I did this little unconf talk.
And every bit of the success
that we've had turning this
to a legal entity, fundraising,
the people coming together,
all of the stuff that we
have done and all the success
that I've had over the last
three or four years talking
about this stuff is based
on open source culture
and it doesn't really have
anything to do with code.
This is what open
source means to me.
And that's why I call this
Open Sourcing Mental Illness.
That's all good.
That's all fine.
But I want to get back
to what I kind of think
is the heart of the
matter and wrap this up.
At the end of the day, this
is what's going on, I believe.
It's that our colleagues
and our friends
and our people, the
people that we work,
our colleagues, our community
members, the folks that we work
with in doing this
kind of stuff,
this sort of tech-oriented
stuff, these tech
professionals, it's our people,
our friends and our colleagues
and our people, a lot of
them suffer in silence,
because they're afraid
to talk about it.
And sometimes some of
them just disappear on us.
They go away for one
reason or another,
and we're left to wonder why
and regret and try to understand
what happened with them.
And there's some that we can
save and there's some that we
can't.
But the only thing that
allows these people
to suffer in silence,
and the only reason
we don't save more of
our kin and our kith
is because of fear.
The only reason is fear.
The only reason that these
people suffer, that we suffer,
and that we lose many of our
friends is because of fear.
We have to choose.
You and I and all
of us have to choose
to be stronger than that fear.
We have to choose
to be stronger.
So thanks for listening.
I hope you'll consider helping
us out with what we do,
sharing our message
and resources,
taking steps to support your
peers, volunteering with us
if you're interested.
You can contact us
on our web site.
If you feel like
donating time or money,
that is very helpful for us too.
It is tax deductible.
So thank you very much.
I appreciate you giving me
the time to speak on this.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: All right, thanks Ed.
And for now, we do
have some mics up
if anyone wants to
ask Ed any questions.
And we also have a
Dory at goed-dory
if you want to ask
your questions there.
So feel free to
step up to the mic
if you have a question Fred.
Otherwise we can go
straight to the Dory.
So we'll go to the Dory.
And so the question
here Ed is, I've
been suffering from an episode
of major depression for two
years.
Do you have advice
for how to combat
negative thoughts at work?
It's often hard for me to see
the positive side of project
proposals and designs even
when it feels like others can.
ED FINKLER: I smirk because
that sounds familiar to me.
Advice is tough
because something
that I've learned
sometimes the hard way
is that you shouldn't
give advice about things
that you don't actually have
enough expertise to speak on.
And one of the things
that also I think you find
is that particularly when
dealing with mental health
issues, things that work
for one person often
don't matter at all.
I feel better when I
drink a lot of water.
I do.
Doesn't mean you're going
to feel better because you
drink lots of water.
Maybe it's a good idea.
Hey, hydrate, that's awesome.
That doesn't mean that's
going to fix your problems.
So advice is tough
because there's not an,
oh, that's the way you
solve that kind of problem
situation for everybody.
I think the thing
that I would suggest
is that the person who's
dealing with this, first off,
that sounds really tough.
And that must be very
hard, particularly
to feel like everybody
else seems like they're
dealing with it OK and I'm not.
I know that's not fun.
I'm not going to say I
understand every single thing
everybody goes through.
I don't.
But that's something I
know a little bit about.
So I can't give you
specific advice.
But what I can say is
that taking that step
to speak to somebody about
it, an particularly somebody
who's a mental health
professional I think
is really important.
That can be really
scary though too.
Oftentimes you're overcoming
a huge amount of inertia
to not do anything.
I've run into
people who have had
maybe occasionally bad
experiences with one therapist
and they're like, I don't ever
want to see somebody again,
it's terrible.
Or there's a lot of
stuff hung up on that.
And it could be many reasons.
The first thing I
hope is that they
have a peer around them who they
can speak with openly about.
And I hope everybody
thinks about
that as maybe you're that peer.
It's one of your co-employees.
It could be anybody
who's saying this.
And this is not
an uncommon thing.
People in this situation are
afraid, typically, very afraid.
And even if you don't deal
with this stuff yourself,
you can have an
immense positive impact
on someone's life by simply
helping them not feel
like they have to be afraid.
And it doesn't mean fixing
their problem for them.
But what it means is that
you're not going to judge them.
You're not going to view
it as a character flaw.
You're going to listen
empathetically and be
encouraging towards them.
Say hey, it's OK.
We're going to figure this out.
The thing that I would
probably do in this case,
from a practical
standpoint, it sounds
like there's good
resources here at Google,
in your EAP and other things.
I would look at what
those resources are.
I would identify
somebody who specifically
deals with depression.
And I'd go try to speak with
a professional about that.
That can be scary.
But it is harder and
it's probably not
going to get better until
you start seeking treatment.
And I guess I'd ask
everybody around here, again,
if we're speaking
openly and honestly
and positively about
mental health, that
is something that's going
to help people like this
be more willing to get
the help that they need
and not have to suffer.
This is exactly what
I'm talking about when
I say people suffer in silence.
And so practically speaking,
you want to get help.
If you need somebody,
find someone hopefully
that you can trust
who maybe you can
talk about this a
little bit with if you
need some help
getting to that point
where you can seek out help.
And maybe they can
help you with that.
Be a person, folks
here, be a person
who somebody could turn to and
say, I'm scared to do this.
Can you help me?
Could you maybe help me
set up the appointment?
Could you maybe go with
me and just sit outside.
I constantly run into folks
who are afraid to go seek help.
And just being that person
for them and saying,
yeah, I'm going to help you.
If you need, I will call
to set that appointment up.
But I'm here for you,
whatever you need.
Being that person is what
this person needs the most.
And it's going to be a lot
easier for them, I think,
if we can all do that.
So that's why I'd say, look at
what you've got in your EAP.
The woman who
spoke earlier I bet
would have some specific
stuff you could help with.
Just go and talk
and say-- you don't
have to spill your whole guts.
Just say, hey, I've been
having some problems.
I think it's related
to depression.
I would like to speak
privately with somebody.
That's all you've got to do.
And that's the first
step to getting better.
And there is treatment.
There are things
available for you.
This can and will get better.
Just got to go seek
the help and find
the people who can
help you with it.
So yeah, that's what I'd say.
SPEAKER: And being mindful of
the time, if you have questions
for Ed, you can always
approach him after the talk,
as he mentioned a
little bit earlier.
I do have one question
of my own as well.
Just in your experience
speaking on the lecture circuit
and also just working
with companies,
are there any success
stories or any use cases
that you've seen
examples from folks
you've spoken with at companies?
ED FINKLER: Yeah, the
first thing I'd say
is that I can speak
to this directly
in that when I go up and
speak about this stuff,
every time I speak I
have people come up to me
and say how important it was
for them to just hear somebody
speak openly without
fear about mental health,
that just that act can be
transformative for them.
And that is humbling
because that is weird.
I'm just up here
babbling about stuff.
I'm oversharing and
acting like I'm an expert.
I don't know if I am.
I don't know.
But just that, I
guess, if you're
talking about success
stories, I see
that as a big success story,
because every time I talk
about it, people tell me that.
We have some examples in
our handbook specifically
that talks about some choices
that certain companies have
made.
I think that the
employee programs
that they have at Keen IO that
were developed by Dr. Jennifer
Akullian, who is one of
our board members, really,
really significant and cool
stuff that they're doing,
essentially a coaching
program for everybody--
really cool stuff.
And so it's not just
mental health stuff,
but it's also like--
God, I hate this
term-- life coaching.
But let's imagine that
it's not as weird as it is.
So stuff like that I
think is really helpful.
There's a company called Olark.
One of the key things that
they do, and also Keen
does, is that they,
in the absence of--
let me step back for a second.
In the absence of
actively telling people
it's OK to talk about this
stuff and to seek help,
the default in our culture
is going to be a negative.
The default is
going to be people
falling back and
assuming that they
can't talk about it safely.
So companies must
actively inform
about the resources they have
and about the values that they
have that this is OK to discuss.
So that means you can't
just put it in a handbook
that somebody gets when
they start their employment
and then throw it in their
desk and they're never
going to look at it again.
You have to actively remind
people again and again,
via multiple ways
of communicating,
that this is
something that's OK,
that our values at this
organization are such.
You must do that.
And the companies
I think have been
most effective at dealing with
that have been companies that
make that part of their values
and their DNA, their culture,
all the time, that
this is just as
important as every
other health aspect.
And we are going to
talk openly about it
and we are going to
actively remind you
that these are the resources
that are available.
And that yes, you
can take a day off.
Reminder, you can take a day
off if you are feeling down
or stressed out or really
anxious or things like that.
You can do that, and that's OK.
And that's just as
valid as if you're sick
or you hurt your back
or anything like that.
It means you're not well
and you can do that.
And that is perfectly valid.
But people need to be
actively reminded of that.
I think that that's a key thing.
SPEAKER: All right.
Well thanks so much
for joining us.
ED FINKLER: Well thank you.
Thank you for having me.
SPEAKER: Very engaging talk.
ED FINKLER: I really
appreciate it.
SPEAKER: And we
appreciate your time.
Thanks everyone for coming.
And we'll see you next
time, Talks at Google.
ED FINKLER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]